bevor das video hat gleich ein paar
sekunden gehen wollten aber eben ganz
kurz für euer ganzes feedback eure
ganzen kommentare und besonders für euer
ganzes mitgefühl unter meinem video vor
zwei tagen gedanken das hat mich sehr
gefreut
die ganzen kommentare durchgelesen und
ich fand es sehr schön
also ich wollte nur kurz danke sagen
jetzt geht's los weil die hektischen
partie accra wird der strand des
deutschen musikhimmel sie hat gestern
ein neues lied namens gucci girl
rausgebracht
[Musik]
und das sieht werden wir uns gleich mal
zusammen anschauen beziehungsweise
anhören zuvor haben wir uns allerdings
erstmal die bewertungen an
zumindest mehr likes als discs nun
werfen wir mal ein blick in die
kommentare
katja setzt sich für den klimawandel ein
ihre brüste sind aus recyceltem plastik
zum glück haben wir ferien und ich muss
mir nicht anhören wie meine ganze schule
das sind in fünf jahren kann man in
jedem spielzeugladen bestimmt die puppen
kaufen was steht auf katjas grabstein
sie wird leider nicht mehr kommen
einfach geschwindigkeit auf das doppelte
dann ist der song auch schneller zu ende
der produzent muss ich auch nur gedacht
haben was mache ich hier also die
kommentare sind eigentlich voll von
witzen über das lied und ja es tut mir
leid ich habe hier in richtig fetten
pickel
allerdings würde ich sagen wir klicken
jetzt einfach mal auf play also es geht
los mit dem coachee logo an der wand und
hier sollen
[Musik]
der beat hört sich so an wie c&a jedes
deutschrap lied gerade ich weiß nicht ob
ich der einzige bin für den sich das
alles irgendwie gleich anhört aber
irgendwie stich keiner in deutschland
mittlerweile noch raus das hat sich
alles gleich und es kommen auch jeden
tag 30 neue lieder aber das ist nur
meine meinung und wir hören jetzt mal
weiter ob sie sich davon eventuell
abheben kann
ich bin ein guter
[Musik]
also ja erste leine und direkt ja wer
hätte es gedacht
[Musik]
was war gut sie hat die noten getroffen
so fertig dass irgendwie mit ein
bisschen musik theoretischen kenntnissen
beurteilen kann und ich fand auch die
laien ganz gut ich bin ein guter girl in
meiner gucci world was ja auch barbie
girl bezogen ist und sie bewegt sich
auch wie eine barbie puppe also es
eigentlich ganz nice katja ergebnisse
verbessert
[Musik]
irgendwie sieht ein bisschen aus wie
eine meerjungfrau jetzt schon wieder
leute hier unten bei mir in die
kommentare schreiben von wegen
die ganze zeit brauchen ja ich meine das
ist natürlich auch meine reaction wenn
ihr euch dass sie nur eine pause anhören
wollt dann guckt in die beschreibung hab
ich euch verlinkt aber ich gebe hier
natürlich meine kommentare dazu ab wo
ich meinen das lied geht bisher eine
halbe minute
und ich muss wirklich sagen ich finds
bisher nice ich würde es nicht hören
aber den umständen entsprechen das ist
von katja ist es eigentlich ganz okay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz kurz ich weiß nicht ob man es
gesehen hat aber in dieser aufnahme ist
in schwarzer rand kann sein dass es bei
mir abgeschnitten dass ich das mal kurz
ein bisschen drüber in der aufnahme aber
seht jetzt hier am rand hier dass das
ist ein dass es ein fehler dass ich auch
wieder auf so eine scheiße achten mal
gucken nur auf die brüste und ich gucke
darauf ob da ein stück fehler drin ist
hier sehen wir auf jeden fall einen hin
und zwar das katjas album am 17 ersten
2020 rauskommen soll ich wusste nicht
dass sie ein album rausbringen will und
ich wusste nicht das datum also an alle
katja native crew
aber ich finds gegen die wirklich
bewundernswert dass sie sich von einem
mädchen das sich halbnackt auf youtube
präsentiert hat entwickelt hat zu einem
mädchen das sich nun in musikvideos halb
nackt präsentiert also vielleicht ist ja
leider doch nicht gerne aber wir hören
mal weiter mir gefällt das richtig gut
diese ganzen parallelen die da irgendwie
so gestrickt werden von barbie girl und
dann hat sie sehr gut tiger genannt aber
genauso dass sie sich bewegt wie diese
barbie und auch in diesem jahr pinke
ferrari um pferde und ein pinkes gucci
schloss hat und so weiter und so fort
finde ich sehr sehr nice allerdings ist
es halt irgendwie auch nur eine mischung
aus einer schlechten shirin david und
haltbar
die titten muss katja diehl 1 war krank
und auch diese bewegungen dabei alter
das sieht echt gut durchdacht und
gekonnt aus
[Musik]
in nagoya japan für die hitliste ich
glaube sie sind nirgendwo hin charts und
ist auch nicht mehr den youtube trends
mit dem song aber okay rapper sind ja
immer so ich mache so viel millionen und
alles bei mir ist krass also ich glaube
ich nach absichtlich übertreibung hier
irgendwie aber ich bin natürlich auch
der musikexperte hat das zweite mal die
palm aus plastik leyen gebracht was ich
bisher auf jeden fall wirklich mal
anmerken muss was er jetzt aber keine
kritik an diesem speziellen songtitel
von katja sondern allgemein an der
kompletten aktuellen deutsch rap
musikszene jeder profiliert sich nur
über materielles dass niemand irgendwie
von wegen ich habe so viel mitgefühl und
so hanna emotionen großes herz alle nur
hierher ich habe hier den porsche ich
habe hier in lambo ich habe mir alles
von gucci und so weiter und so fort
katja wie wärs wenn ja okay zu katja
passes jetzt glaube ich nicht wenn sie
über die wahre liebe singen würde aber
bisher handelt der ganze song von gucci
und tippen aber wir sind auch erst bei
der hälfte
[Musik]
ich weiß du hast nicht aber
jetzt kommt das große aber also den
kompletten inhalt des liedes also die
kompletten lyrics et cetera worum es
darin geht das unterstütze ich
keineswegs bin ich echt kacke dass man
nur noch über so was singen kann
anscheinend aber was man wirklich dem
ganzen lied lassen muss es ist krass gut
produziert der beat ist krass und das
komplette video ist krass bis auf den
einschnitt fehler zu beginnen aber hier
diese komplette szenerie das alles wie
das aufgebaut ist die ganzen farben hier
mit dem green screen und dem himmel und
dann tanzt die hier um im freizügigen
barbie kostüm hier ist wirklich noch der
hund jetzt plötzlich wie patrick der
start mal bist du aber wir hören mal
weiter dass es van dorado punkt kommt
ein paar sekunden später also ich habe
keine ahnung was bei einer webseite ich
hier gerade gelandet bin hier gibt es
auf jeden fall die alles drin flatrates
die mega krass ist da gibt's live cams
cam girls hier so komisch in chats
videos micaela schäfer ja geil dass du
dafür werden
ich bin und er mit dem song ich finde
den song komplett krass gemacht
produziert und das ganze musik videos
auch geil ich finde auch die parallelen
die gezogen werden zu barbie girl finde
ich sehr cool class ist ein bisschen
einfallslos wenn man das sowieso
komplett kopiert und so eine höhere
barbie durchgesetzt und so weiter und so
fort aber es macht irgendwo sind und ist
auch unterhaltsam und macht auch la
laune sich das ganze anzuhören sage ich
mal und auch hier wie das alles
dargestellt ist mit den ganzen wunden
knalligen farben und die mit dem pink
und ihre ganzen outfits und sehr
freizügig und so das passt ja alles hier
und genauso hätte ich mir das auch
vorgestellt und es ist auch ein
deutlicher schritt nach vorne von jetzt
beispielsweise und dem dem anderen der
frage sind das noch mal sex tape und
dicke lippen hat sauna gemacht
allerdings muss sich halt wirklich auf
der anderen seite sagen und ich weiß es
jetzt einen kritikpunkt nur im gegensatz
zu zehn positiven punkten die ich zu
diesem lied bisher gesagt habe aber der
kritikpunkt überwiegt für mich trotzdem
den ganzen positiven dinge wenn ich
meine fanpages in den instagram
entdecken oder wie das da heißt
benachrichtigung sehe dann noch viele
von meinen fanpages von jungen mädels
die ich schon mal getroffen
die 14 jahre alt sind like dann halt die
bilder von katja wo sie halt ja ich weiß
nicht ob so gut ist dass sie so ein
vorbild ist versteht was ich meine aber
vielleicht nicht auf so pingelig mehr
okay jetzt wird doch ihr album hier
beworben wird das am 17
er bietet auch gut aber gute freunde das
war meine reaktion auf den neuen song
von katja krawitz namens gucci girl wie
hat euch das noch gefallen hier oben ist
eine umfrage bestimmt gern mal ab sagte
er so jamann megageil dann so ich weiß
es nicht oder was er schreibt mir zudem
mit sie gerne auch mal eure ausführliche
meinungen zu dem song hier unten in die
kommentare wird mich auf jeden fall mega
deal interessiert mit euch da mal so ein
bisschen drüber zu schreiben weil ich
finds gut
ich finde es komisch dass er sage aber
was ja gerade schon gesagt habe diese
komplette person katja krawitz ich weiß
es nicht ich bin gespannt ich bin
wirklich gespannt auf das album wäre mir
die album box definitiv hier bei mir
eine vitrine stellen
aber gut freude wenn ich meine reaktion
auf den siebzigern von katja gefallen
hat der last auf jeden fall einen daumen
und hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal falls noch keine
zahl der luchse sei das ist kostenlos da
passt keine videos mehr
[Musik]